let's say you get a windfall thanks to
your excellent contributions to your
employer like me or you've inherited
chunk of change from a distant uncle or
you found a few grand in a suitcase on
the side of the highway whatever you got
some extra bread let's figure out what
to do with that extra scratch it's not
easy to make sense of your finances I'm
shahim the serie poor and I want to meet
people with an obsession to beat the
system and never leave money on the
table and who better to tell me what to
do with my money
than a finance expert I luckily enough
I've got three of them right here so
we've got some extra money bring holes
in our pockets what should we be
thinking about if you have toxic credit
card debt attack that first these are
your double-digit interest rates it's
it's moving you backwards very quickly
please get rid of that don't even think
about it if you've got a 15% credit card
or a 23% credit card and at the same
time you've got a three or four percent
student loan hanging out there we might
be looking at your credit cards first
and think about where those dollars are
best spent going forward at right now
we're concerned about the highest
costing dollar your credit card is a
debt that is typically based on money
that you've already spent you're
finished it's time to pay off the debt
you'll hear financial planners often
talk about an emergency fund
then you'll hear them all say three to
six months is what you need three to six
months three to six months of your
living expenses in cash so the most
important thing about portfolio
construction is understanding which
risks your portfolio is open to so if
you bought 100% of one individual stock
and then that business goes out of
business you go to zero that's go to
zero risk volatility drawdowns economic
events this is part of the game and if
you're not equipped to handle the
inevitabilities of markets going down
and economic cycles turning over you
better reassess your situation so you
don't have to be emotionally impacted by
these types of events ideally these will
be diversified mutual funds index funds
diversification diversification
diversification make sure that you do
have some fixed income in the portfolio
even though fixed income is not going to
give you the rate of return that stock
market does it serves as a temper in
your portfolio it reduces the volatility
it's not there to make you rich but it's
there to help you sleep at night
how much volatility are we talking about
when it comes to what what allows you to
sleep at night if your bonus has a
sizable tax impact or even takes you
into a higher tax bracket check to see
if your employer has a deferred
compensation plan the advantage of that
is that your compensation this bonus
that you receive is not taxed to you but
goes into an account which will only be
taxed to you when you begin taking the
funds out so you've paid off your debt
and built a solid rainy day fund Bravo
now you're ready to invest if you're
anything like me and terrified about
managing your money you may want to hire
someone like Douglas Erica or Ian let's
ask Bloomberg reporter Suzanne Wooley
about what we should be looking for if
we're looking to hire a financial
advisor fees sometimes we might not pay
so much attention to because sometimes
they don't seem like they're that big
over the years they really can mush
and eat away at your investment
particularly if we're going into sort of
a slower growth environment a lot of
people like fee-only planners and part
of that is just because it's so
transparent you want to know what you're
paying the real key is just to be very
upfront and ask your planner what are
your fees how are they structured and
whether they are a fiduciary this means
that they have to sell you the product
that is in your best interest maybe it's
time for a financial tune-up and for you
maybe that saving cash or paying down
debt but personal finance is personal so
see what's right for you